welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and if you haven't made
your way to the theaters to watch
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania please
do it's finally dropped Marvel Studios
has officially opened the floodgates on
phase five with the quantum realm baby
which has plenty of crazy ways to
connect to phase six and Kang Dynasty
today I'll be explaining the ending and
trying to answer any lingering questions
left behind and fair warning before I
dive in that I'll be spoiling this
entire movie if you haven't seen it yet
so you've been warned just letting you
know thanks to Rocket money for
sponsoring today's video more about them
in a minute like I said earlier this
movie opens the door to phase five and
we really get to learn more about Kang
and his variants as we know this
ultimately leads to phase six's Secret
Wars so there's a lot of pressure on
Jeff loveness and the Gang to really
deliver a well-rounded King the
Conqueror Eric boss has a breakdown of
Easter eggs that are going to be coming
out on the channel soon so I won't be
breaking down the full movie just the
ending for you go on over to Eric's
breakdown to get the full in-depth
analysis and plot summary time for my
ending explained as we know when Janet
was stuck in the quantum realm she met
Heng who fell from the sky he said he
was a scientist and traveler in his ship
4 was busted Janet helped him fix the
core and in doing so all his memories of
him killing people on different planets
in different timelines Janet said hell
no and using the last bit of Pim Tech
she had blew the energy core to an
astronomical size so Kang needs that
pintech to decrease its size and get out
of the quantum realm he succeeds and
makes a portal though it's not open for
long he ends up going 1v2 against Scott
and hope and the portal closes leaving
the two stuck in the quantum realm and
Kang sucked into his energy core dead
using the device that put the signal
into the quantum realm Cassie is able to
reopen a portal and get her dad and hope
out safely she's created some sort of
Metro who like bus from Earth 616 took
the quantum realm also I guess Cassie
Hank and Hope's brain could make
something that could reach the people in
the quantum realm like trying to find
them so of course it's after Scott and
Janet were stuck in now freed of course
who would have thought I think one of
the biggest unanswered questions is
traveling between our world and the
quantum realm is it solved now is it
less hazardous how was the device Cassie
made now able to pull Scott and hope out
so at the beginning Cassie noted her
device can send a signal to the quantum
realm like a subatomic Hubble telescope
and collect data and send it back once
the portal closed Cassie immediately
went to work on the signal again now I
assume since the device is collecting
data it collected the information from
the first signal with Modoc then when
Kang sent the signal back opening a
portal in their basement it received
that signal and collected the data from
both parties now allowing Cassie the
ability to reopen portals between Both
Worlds so long as she has the pimp
particles of pimtech is it now solved
the transportation between the two
worlds I'd say yes is it less hazardous
absolutely also important to mention
they don't even have to go into the
quantum realm now they can just monitor
it from the outside maybe even share
resources
we also received two Stingers the first
came before the credits we saw an arena
of Tanks different variants all cheering
like a football stadium and I want to be
at that game we focus on the three that
present themselves as the leaders a
pharaoh ramitet what we think is the
Scarlet Centurion and immortus people
have been waiting for these Kings and
begging for them remember we saw the
little Moon Knight call out in the third
episode I think the biggest takeaway
here is that a they refer to Kang the
Conqueror not only as dead but as the
exiled one and B they're afraid of us
entering the Multiverse amortis said
they will take everything we have as I'm
sure boss will get into the backstory of
each one I'll just give you a mini
rundown more so a trip down memory lane
if you will in the finale of Loki season
1 he who remains mentions eons ago a
variant of himself lived on Earth in the
31st Century a scientist who discovered
the universe is stacked on top of his
own during then the other kings also
figured it out and like he who remains
says naturally they made contact and for
a while there was peace until there
wasn't and came the multiversal war that
he who remains allegedly stopped by
weaponizing Elias and isolating their
timeline he said some of his variants
were good but some were bad and just
wanted to rule we're seeing that with
this scene these are the bad variants
their motive seems connected to the fear
of losing their reign but also having to
fight the good versions of themselves
and unfortunately I think King the
Conqueror might have been a good version
and because he fought them he was exiled
I think people that can directly sort of
affect the Multiverse like America
Chavez Dr Strange Loki Scott and hope
maybe even white Vision will be the
first major targets for the Kings Marvel
movies have big budgets sounds nice
right if you want a big budget for your
life rocket money can help with that it
makes saving money super easy rocket
money used to be true bill but true bill
mutated from a bill management app into
a full money on management Powerhouse
rocket money rocket money does
everything true build did and more
helping 3.4 million members take control
of their finances with easy use features
that put you back in charge of your
finances and I'm one of that 3.4 million
I love rocket money I'm obsessed one of
Rocket money's best features is that it
helps you find and cancel all your
unwanted subscriptions I was wasting
hundreds of dollars every month on stuff
I didn't even use and now I can use
rocket money smart savings account to
put that money aside instead and let me
tell you I genuinely did I absolutely
did rocket money helped me get my phone
bill down because ATT is coming for me I
just choose the amount I want to save
and how frequently rocket money
automatically deposits my money into the
savings fund that I can withdraw from
any time that is amazing for the my
money I'm spending instead of saving I
use the budgeting tool it monitors my
spending by category sends notifications
when I've exceeded my spending limits
and visualizes my spend to earn ratio by
month quarter or Year and I love it
rocket money can even negotiate bills
from internet service bills to cable and
phone bills I didn't even know that
those could be a negotiated just upload
a photo of your bill and Rocket money
does the rest I literally said this
earlier it bought my phone bill and I'm
not joking once you've signed up you can
unlock more features in premium it's so
easy to use that there's no reason not
to take control of your finances to try
rocking money out for free and support
our Channel head to rocketmoney.com new
rockstars or click the link in the video
description below and I know you guys
are doing it it's January it's February
come on get your finances in order the
second Stinger was a crown Victorian
like showroom a crowd gathered for a
very steampunky looking device
introduced by Victor timely another
variant and in the crowd it's lokia
Mobius disguised at the same timely
costumes this scene but like one of
those old-timey snake oil salesman shows
you know I mean like the Sweeney Todd Mr
pirelli's Miracle Elixir now this this
really is shaping what happened after
Sylvie killed he who remained right
we're left with Loki Mobius searching
for the Kang variants now we don't know
if their motive is to prune them or kill
all the king variants but it sure as
hell looks like it now Victor timely is
a brilliant inventor strategist just all
around has an unfathomable knowledge and
advanced technology he founded timely
Wisconsin and introduced basic
principles of Robotics and computer
science they also created the original
Human Torch but also made a portal to
chronopolis so what does this all mean
for SC and Victor timely now Mt actually
made a valid argument on inside Marvel
about Victor timely wanting to find
white Vision as a robotics expert and
being the Kang variant that just wanders
her I love this idea and also I just
need to call out Mt because he got two
things from this movie ages ago he
pitched modok's broken bones going into
the quantum realm which is why his limbs
to head ratios are low off and now this
I know there's more that he probably
guessed but damn our boy is two for two
I love him I think another important
question to note at the end is whether
or not Kang the Conqueror is actually
dead so far we only have confirmation
from the other variants but what do we
know from his energy core that can lead
us to believe that maybe still alive now
I don't know how highly this can be
connected but worth mentioning we've
already met America Chavez whose powers
are of the ability to travel the
Multiverse if her power to jump the
Multiverse is anything like the core of
the multiversal engine Kang could simply
just be living deeper within the quantum
realm or in a separate Universe I'm
basing this off the fact that Chavez's
moms were sent to an alternate universe
when she was scared by a bee so if the
engine's core exploded it could have
sucked him into a different Universe
with no way to escape again I think
Chavez's raw power when she couldn't
control it could match that of the
energy course we also saw what happens
when you go into the energy core all the
possible ant-mans the Schrodinger's box
and you are the cat as Modoc says it's
possible King had to live with every
outcome of himself until his mind
disintegrates but it appears like the
core is dead and exploded so if he
traveled to the core he could be dead
after the energy ball died but I think
the first possibility of being somewhere
else is highly likely you let me know
what you think if he's dead or alive or
if he's just trapped in his own mind
there's also now a super Advanced ant
colony uh okay which truly are the
heroes of this film Hank's ants are also
sucked into the quantum realm and fell
into a Time expansion field and lived
thousands of years over the span of a
couple days they built a technocratic
civilization now we already know there's
different sort of quadrants to the
quantum realm but now confirm there's a
Time expansion field that led a
different part run by Hank's ants
leaving the ants behind in the quantum
realm they'll probably help rebuild
everything damaged by King and I think
that's amazing which brings me to my
theory what could possibly happen in the
quantum realm now that there's no King
how will they rebuild civilization how
can you come to the quantum realm I
think it'll play like the Planet Nowhere
in Guardians of the Galaxy the holiday
special and people whose homes were
destroyed by Thanos the quantum realm
might be new home to displace humans we
know Cassie is a super activist
protesting and trying to make the world
a better place for people that aren't
the universe's number one threat like
her dad for the little guy as they say
so I think Hank and her will continue
finding resources for the quantum room
seeing as Cassie was so sad when she saw
what Kang did to that group of people
just looking for her she wants to fix
her mistakes started with helping
rebuild the quantum realm and when times
get tough on Earth possibly moving some
folks in this Theory video should come
out like shortly after this one so click
on over there for more information if
you want to know more information on how
the ants and Cassie will assist and
travel to the quantum realm this brings
us to our final bit so Moda he's just
dead he's dead I I think he is I think
Modoc is dead I don't think Modoc is
coming back but we do know there's a
Multiverse and different modocs out
there right so what I find interesting
is the probability field or the storm of
the core we met one Ant-Man that was a
Baskin Robbins got laying out of the
thousand of Ant-Man scotlands so there's
a probability for every Modoc there's a
thousand Darren crosses that never
became MoDOT so maybe we can see a
darinless Modoc or another Modoc that's
not Darren but someone else who was
sucked and broken down into the quantum
realm which is Bonkers I know and that
was it for our ending explain for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania there's
a lot of questions and theories that
we'll be answering on inside Marvel on
the Deep dive and our Theory videos
everywhere keep an eye out for them make
sure to follow me at Lulu underscore
Clemons all new Rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love and a reminder that
our new channel the Deep dive is
launching Friday February 17th and
here's a little preview
hey y'all
[Applause]
I'm Eric Boston this is new rockstars
the Deep dive in which I go beyond
hunting Easter eggs so try to decode
what the eggs mean is this Kang variant
truly surprised here or is he performing
a script that requires him to act
surprised
[Music]
initiating spin